[Music]
people living in a Northeast Valley
neighborhood are fed up with the
speeding on their Block it's so bad one
woman says she's had her property
crashed into eight times in seven years
the most recent happening just two weeks
ago Madison Kimbrough joins us live near
Charleston and Nellis tonight with this
story you'll only see on the news now
Rosemary Romero lives here and as you
can see parts of her property have been
destroyed by a cars several cars
repeatedly speeding in the area ending
up crashing into her yard and she and
other neighbors have had enough and are
calling on their local County
Commissioner for help
this is the a time they got into my
house eight times already I used my
homeowners insurance most of the time
most of the cars that they come they
don't have insurance they take off Hit
and Run
so of course now my insurance is going
upper and upper and it's ridiculous
Rosemary Romero doesn't feel safe in her
home anymore she's lived at this
residence in the Northeast Valley for
over 30 years and says within the last
seven She always fears it may be her
last as time and time again cars can be
seen and heard speeding by many crashing
into her property they broke the whole
window they broke they got into the
garage I think I need to like maybe
bumps you know those bumps and maybe put
some crust
grants Lanes right there so you know for
the kids like when they're crossing the
park they almost see the kid the other
day they're not gonna be happy until
they kill one of these kids
Romero says she and other neighbors
created a petition for change to give to
their County Commissioner District e
representative tick sagerblum but never
heard back some for someone gets killed
out here you know and I feel like I'm
trapped in my own home since this you
know I get out here and I get nervous
going up and down the sidewalk
other than speed bumps residents say
this block of Marion Drive is in
desperate need of better lighting also
an additional crosswalk with blinking
lights would help reporting live in the
Northeast Valley Madison Kimbrough 8
News Now